some of the coolest examples
of the use of crowdsourcing
in places you would not expect come from
nasa the space agency in the u.s has used
open innovation and crowdsourcing systematically
for the past decade they have learned to use
open innovation to solve problems in the
space station to help think about how to
keep astronauts safe and healthy while they're
in space and even how to deal with space poo
so nasa has thought a lot about how to
incorporate open innovation into their processes
another cool example comes from the defense
department in the u.s where they actually started
challenges to help create the autonomous driving
revolution that all of us will be seeing over the
next few decades they started challenges and and
and contests to enable anybody from around the us
to participate and create solutions to creating
software and robots that could allow cars to
travel on their own so in key key areas space
exploration for humanity autonomous driving
open innovation has played an important role
in unlocking innovation from around the world